- Vaccines.
Cue the controversy.
(soulful electronic music)
- [Female Interviewer] So to be clear,
you believe that your son's autism
is linked to the vaccination?
- [Male Voice] If they don't vaccinate,
we could have a measles outbreak,
and it could become an epidemic.
- [Donald Trump] This
little beautiful baby,
and you pump, and I
mean it looks just like
its meant for a horse!
- [Soft Female Voice] Never
has there been a safe vaccine.
Never will there be
a safe vaccine.
- Vaccines don't cause
autism and they save millions of lives
every year.
- Where is the published peer
reviewed evidence?
- The virus is so contagious
that if exposed to it
- I wanna know the truth,
I'm not anti-vaccine,
I want safe vaccines.
- Listening to the media,
you can really lose your mind
to try figure out what the
real deal about vaccines is,
because there's so many
contradictory points!
You hear people screaming
all of these things,
you don't know what to believe.
And I empathize with the person who
doesn't have a great medical education,
to understand what's true and what's not.
We're venturing out of New
York City and we're gonna
ask people what they think,
or what they believe,
or what they know about vaccines.
(quirky jazz music)
(keyboard clicking)
(soft piano melody)
To put it simply,
a vaccine is an introduction
of a virus or part of a virus
that allows your body to see it,
to get used to it,
to build up its defense,
and be protected if the
real thing does come along.
What do you think about vaccinations?
- I don't believe in them
- You don't believe in them?
- Hmm-mm
- How come?
- I think they're real like, experiments,
and the put the,
the, you know,
virus in us so,
- Did your doctor try and like,
push you or convince you to do 'em?
- Yeah.
Like, always.
They always do that.
- Why do you think they do that?
- They get paid for this shit!
Look.
(both laugh)
- Thank you so much, I appreciate it
(crowd awws)
- Vaccines are not a
blockbuster hit for doctors
or pharmaceutical companies.
Most of the money that's dedicated
to this research goes to universities.
(static buzzes)
(soft pensive bells)
- It's as heart wrenching
as it gets, autism and children.
- Well the vast majority of
medical experts insist that
vaccines are generally safe.
- You're going to stand on
the stage and say vaccines
and autism are unrelated?
It is the most bogus
- I've seen the correlations
between multiple vaccines
at a very young age,
and autism, and other
problems that people have.
- People think
autism or whatever
is a risk of
- Yeah that's going around.
Can I tell you a like
a little history about,
it's really interesting.
So in 1998,
this guy, he was a doctor at the time,
his name is Dr. Wakefield.
He did this study on 12 kids,
not 1,000 kids, not 1 million, 12.
Found that there was an
increased risk of getting autism
if they got vaccine,
this specific vaccine, MMR vaccine.
Measles, mumps and rubella.
He was paid 500 thousand dollars
to try and create this link
because of a law company that
wanted to make lawsuits, right?
- Right
- And this is only
12 kids he tested!
So not like thousands, or 100 thousand,
and he found that there
was an increased risk,
and it was published.
They took away his medical license,
there was a really big deal about it.
I cannot say this more clearly;
there has been no association
between autism and vaccination.
Zero.
None.
- If you had to convince
someone that told you that
despite like the best
research that you've seen
that there is no link to autism,
that they still believe that
there is a correlation somehow.
- I would suggest to them that
having a child with autism
is a lot better than having a dead child.
You know what I mean?
- What I do empathize
with you, and understand,
is that the government telling people
they have to get vaccines.
- Right.
If you don't do it, they're not to
be registered in school.
- Can't go to school.
(soft upbeat drums)
- That's a great
thing to talk about because
in one sense you want to
have control over your body,
and what treatments are taken,
and what illnesses you have,
that's your right to
choose and all of that but,
on the other hand,
if you don't get immunized,
you can harm other people.
And the reason why you
put people at risk is
because not every child
can get the vaccine.
Not every child can be immunized.
Some have a genetic deficiency in
their immune system where
vaccines don't work on them.
- In France we have a culture pro-vaccine
but now."
- I've heard recently in France
it's changing a little bit,
- Yeah that's true
- and they're thinking
about making it a law.
The international community stands
firmly with the US on this one.
They believe every child
should be vaccinated,
and in fact, there is such
a shortage in vaccines
throughout the world UNICEF
says that about one child
dies every 20 seconds from a disease
preventable by vaccine.
I heard today and I hear a
lot of times from my patients
that they worry that
their kids are getting
too many vaccines all at once,
or they're getting too many boosters
in the first two years of life,
and look, the important
things to remember,
and what I really want to reassure you of,
is that that schedule
is there for a reason.
It's not based on a personal whim,
it's not based on one
person's expert opinion.
It's based on data.
Quality studies that
prove this is the best way
to deliver those vaccines.
(quirky jazz music)
(keyboard clicking)
(smooth jazz music)
I tell this
over and over again to my patients,
and especially when I'm
giving them the flu shot
that they can't get the
flu from the flu shot.
The reason why people start
thinking that is because
the season of when we give the flu shot
is the most common time
of year that people
generally get colds and other viruses.
Just because two things happen
generally at the same time
doesn't mean one of those things
caused the other to happen.
- For those that were talking about
chemicals being found in our vaccines,
it's true that there are small
minute quantities of chemicals,
like for example, aluminum,
that stabilize the vaccine or help prevent
bacterial and fungal growth but,
the amount of aluminum
that's found in a vaccine
is less that the amount
you find in baby formula
or breast milk, think about that.
Just like with everything else in life,
vaccines do carry some risks.
However, most of these
risks are fairly minor.
Redness or swelling of the injection site,
a mild fever,
nothing serious.
There are more serious complications
like anaphylaxis
which is a life threatening
allergic reaction,
but it happens less than
one in 1 million cases
and can be fully reversible
by a healthcare professional.
As a doctor, my job is to
always weigh the benefits
versus the risk when doing anything.
You're always forced to make decisions,
and a lot of the time you
have to make decisions
with incomplete information.
But your job is to find the
best incomplete information
and use that to make a decision.
In this case, for vaccines,
we may learn something
new about vaccines in the coming years.
We may learn that they
weren't as good as we thought,
or there is some other adverse
effects that we haven't thought of,
but right now, the information
that's available to you,
the quality information,
shows that vaccines are good.
They have higher benefit than risk,
and they protect us.
So there is no doubt, vaccinate
yourself and your kids.
(static buzzing)
- Hey guys, thanks for watching.
If you haven't already, hit
that subscribe button now
to get new videos every week.